vous découvrez le mannequin new york
tandis klaus et ses poses parfois
suggestives ou ses danseuses sexy
ne vous y méprenez pas car cette femme
cache en réalité un très gros qi 236
alors forcément avec un tel quotient
intellectuel elle ne cherche pas
n'importe quel mec
elle a donc décidé de faire passer un
test de qi à son prétendant dès le
premier rendez vous comme l explique si
bien il ya beaucoup d'hommes qui sont
séduisants mais s'ils ne sont pas
intelligents cela enlève de la valeur à
leurs physiques voilà de quoi déjà
éliminé sans doute ce garçon seconde se
convertissent à fait deux minutes
[Musique]
franchement mais ça fout
c'est vrai oui moi j'adore ça
franchement parce que ça crée la
cohérence à leur être pas
je jouerai mais je trouve que ça créé
voilà on a des affinités on est du même
niveau intellectuel c'est formidable
bravo reste c'est moi la première chose
que vous regardez vous benhaim chez un
homme son sourire
et ses
coulisses cher important parce que
béatrice ses yeux non c'est vrai ouais
c'est
vraiment de me dire bouffon et le cul
s'il
a perdu
ses yeux si l'on regardé ses yeux son
regard
si les plus grands clubs il
encore
sa beauté intérieure et son bull
gagné c'est un homme alors je vous dis
moi je regarde si j'ai pas que je
regarderai en particulier oui c'est un
feeling
je suis pas tiré par un physique et le
ciré parité par la personne mais la
vérité ça serait quoi sans mentir
vraiment ce jour c'est la manche ne
tirez pas l'enjeu très important moi le
parfum à l'odeur pas vraiment moi j'ai
logiciel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais son odeur aurel naturel au réveil
ou un parfum même pas moi je tombe
amoureux d'un parfois oui c'est quoi ton
parfum féminin préféré tordu ans
skaff l'ordre
c'est quoi si si je sais ce que c'est
c'est quoi c'est le truc là chez ceux
qui font la lingerie la ba oui
c'est pas la wii
c'est pas un vrai parfum si tu connais
toi
tu en sais rien on met à chanter 3p dans
ta vie tu vois
c'est sûr ouais c'est quand on maintient
ses dehors mais on tient à lui de johnny
c'est quoi
c'est quoi c'est
une brume de table